Oi boa tarde pessoal bom eu sou o Diogo
viagem e eu sou um biólogo de formação e
o inventor por hobby e isso
provavelmente fez eu me tornar um
cientista e eu vou falar um pouquinho de
ciência hoje para vocês mas eu vou falar
sem o linguajar científico vou tentar
trazer um pouquinho mais pelo linguajar
humano é um
Bom vamos lá é o que eu vou trazer para
vocês é um pouquinho de biotecnologia EA
biotecnologia voltada para a saúde
principalmente a saúde humana e para
falar de biotecnologia no ponto que eu
quero é preciso entender
superficialmente sobre células-tronco Eu
imagino que a maioria de vocês aqui já
ouviram falar de células-tronco
certo a célula-tronco é uma célula que
por definição ela consegue se
diferenciar ela se transformar em um
outro tipo de célula
é mas é
não sei se a maioria de vocês aqui sabe
que existem diferentes tipos de
células-tronco e essa diferença está
relacionado com o potencial de cada
célula tronco se diferenciar em outros
tipos de célula a célula tronco mais
comum ela é chamada de célula tronco
adulta porque ela tem esse nome porque
ela se mantém até nos indivíduos adultos
são todos nós aqui nessa sala temos
células-tronco adultas
a célula-tronco adulta ela ela tem um
potencial uma capacidade de se
transformar em outras células bem
limitada e geralmente está relacionado
com aquele órgão aonde ela normalmente
fica então uma célula que muita gente já
ouviu falar que as células-tronco da
medula ela consegue virar as células do
sangue uma célula de defesa uma hemácia
uma plaqueta
e assim por diante então outros tipos as
telas da placenta são relação com adulta
e também cela de polpa de dente só que
existe um outro tipo de célula-tronco
que é a célula-tronco pluripotente
também chamada de célula-tronco
pluripotente embrionária por quê
e essa célula tronco ela tem um
potencial de se transformar em outras
células muito maior do que a
célula-tronco adulta então basicamente
ela pode virar quase todas as células do
nosso do nosso corpo e inclusive células
muito especializadas como um neurônio
uma célula da retina uma célula do
coração uma célula do fígado e a
célula-tronco embrionária recebe esse
nome porque ela vem de um embrião então
Normalmente quando se faz fertilização
in vitro nem todos os embriões são
utilizados no Brasil é permitido pegar
esses embriões para serem utilizados em
pesquisa e é daí que as células troncos
às células-troncos vem não seria muito
interessante a Gente desculpa como vende
o embrião existem diversas questões
éticas e religiosas que envolvem o uso
dessas ela então o climático no seria
interessante existir uma célula com esse
potencial só que sem ter esses problemas
éticos envolvidos para nossa sorte
existe essa célula no final de 2006 o
grupo de pesquisadores japoneses
conseguiu criar uma célula-tronco
pluripotente
eles criaram essa célula a partir de uma
de uma célula de um indivíduo adulto
então eles pegaram uma célula da pele a
desculpa essas ela que eles criaram eles
têm ela tem o mesmo potencial que a
célula-tronco embrionária Então ela
consegue virar todos esses tipos de
célula e essa célula-tronco pluripotente
foi chamada de induzida Por que você
pega uma célula do indivíduo adulto pode
ser uma célula da pele uma célula do
bulbo do cabelo até mesmo uma célula da
urina e através de uma modificação
genética você consegue induzir você faz
com que essas ela passe a ser uma
célula-tronco pluripotente induzida
e o que é mais interessante dessa
tecnologia é que isso pode ser feito de
qualquer indivíduo então qualquer um
aqui nessa sala pode ter uma
célula-tronco pluripotente induzida e eu
imagino que vocês devem estar se
perguntando tá que legal né Para quê que
eu vou querer ter uma célula-tronco
pluripotente induzida pois bem a
resposta é que provavelmente o futuro da
Medicina vai passar pelas células-tronco
pluripotentes induzidas e nos próximos
slides eu vou mostrar para vocês porque
é a primeira aplicação de uma
célula-tronco pluripotente induzida está
relacionada com o desenvolvimento de
remédios
e cosméticos também quando essas
empresas vão desenvolver um produto novo
eles precisam é isso passa por diversas
etapas e entre elas existe a etapa dos
testes em animais
Só que tem um problema você testar em
animais tem dois problemas O primeiro é
muita gente não gosta que que animais
sejam utilizados nesse tipo de pesquisa
se devem lembrar do Instituto Royal no
final de 2013 onde invadiram lá e
soltaram os Animais
isso pouco tempo depois fez com que o
governo de São Paulo proibisse o uso de
animais em testes na fabricação de
cosméticos então mostrem a importância
de se eliminar é isso e o segundo
problema é animais são animais seres
humanos são seres humanos ainda existe
uma a doença Então como um exemplo um
coração de um camundongo ele bate 400
vezes por minuto o nosso bate de 60 a 70
Então existe uma uma diferença bem
importante é mas ainda assim Os animais
são os melhores modelos é e como então
essa célula-tronco pluripotente
Poderia ajudar nesse.
e pela capacidade dessas ela disse fazer
se gerar novas células específicas como
do coração e do fígado a gente pode usar
as células específicas nas etapas de
desenvolvimento desse produto então a
gente faz uma seleção prévia dos das
moléculas que essas empresas vão criar
na célula humana e vai ter uma
especificidade do ser humano Então
quando você precisa levar essas
moléculas que você precisa testar essas
moléculas no Animal você não vai levar
500 moléculas e matar sei lá 10 mil
animais você consegue selecionar e levar
assim
50 moléculas apenas faz testes em
animais e também diminuir em 10 vezes o
número de animais utilizados
não é uma eliminação dos Animais em
pesquisas Mas é uma diminuição e que já
é um grande. Só que seria muito legal se
a gente conseguisse eliminar uso de
animais em pesquisa e certamente e essa
situação tá chegando muito próxima de
acontecer e novamente baseada no uso de
células-tronco
pluripotentes induzidas
essa tecnologia que pode substituir o
uso de animais é chamada de o corpo
humano no chip
e o que é isso basicamente
pessoal de engenharia conseguiu criar um
chip com uma circulação
canais ninhos minúsculos Onde você
consegue passar um fluido ali que seria
semelhante simulando o sangue e criar
uma rede dentro disso
conectando pontos específicos como vocês
podem ver aqui nessa figura esses pontos
expecificos vocês seria possível colocar
micro órgãos micro órgãos que seriam
gerados a partir das células-tronco
pluripotentes induzidas que a gente
consegue colocar lá um micro coração um
micro pulmão e conectar eles e por que
isso poderia substituir o uso de animais
porque aqui a ideia de estar se criando
um sistema a gente Dessa drogas em
animais por causa do sistema completo do
animal a gente não pode testar qualquer
coisa no ser humano agora com esses
microorganismos e a gente é conseguiria
ter uma análise de um composto de uma de
uma maneira mais Ampla então na figura
da direita a gente pode entender melhor
né O Ali os micro órgãos estariam
conectados E qual seria ideia se você
faz um remédio que vai ser inalado você
pega e injeta a molécula daquele remédio
pelo pelo pulmão e que ele vai passar
pelo pulmão vai ter o ser feito no
pulmão mas o que sobrar daquilo ainda
vai passar em todo o sistema Então você
vai conseguir ver o efeito daquela
molécula também nos outros órgãos
Quem é E aí sim conseguindo que uma
análise mais complexa e isso é uma
tecnologia com grande potencial para
eliminar o uso de animais Mas lembra que
eu falei que o mais importante dessa
tecnologia é que cada pessoa pode ter um
pode ter a sua célula-tronco
pluripotente induzida
isso permite que associado com essa
tecnologia se desenvolva a medicina
personalizada
se você quiser não sei se vocês já
ouviram falar nisso mas o que qual é a
ideia da Medicina personalizada A ideia
é que cada pessoa aqui também vai poder
ter o seu corpo humano não chip então
numa situação hipotética imagina que
vocês descobrem que têm uma doença
grave e que vocês precisam tomar um
remédio tarja preta cheio de efeitos
colaterais
e que existem alguns tipos de remédio
que funcionam para algumas pessoas e
outras que as outras você vai ficar
tomando cada remédio para descobrir o
que é melhor para você não se você tiver
uma alternativa como essa você pode
pegar o composto de cada um desses
remédios e usar no seu corpo humano não
chip e ver qual desses remédios Vai ter
o efeito Mais Positivo para sua doença e
viraria um menor efeito colateral é e
isso seriam uma seleção de remédio né
isso não seria só para os remédios
existentes por remédios novos que estão
em fases até mesmo de
desenvolvimento poderiam serem
identificados usando isso então a
medicina personalizada Talvez seja algo
muito próximo de acontecer
Quem é E aí avançando um pouquinho na
complexidade a gente pode falar da
Medicina regenerativa e isso me empolga
muito mais porque é hoje No Brasil
existem 37 mil pessoas na fila de espera
de transplantes de órgão
é obviamente tem mais gente precisando
de um órgão do que pessoas
doando órgãos e
Ah e ainda existe o problema de rejeição
então você pode ser lá o primeiro da
fila e quando aparecer um órgão ele não
se compatível com você
bom então se vai continuar esperando não
seria muito interessante se você pudesse
comprar o seu órgão a hora que você
precisasse
isso será possível também baseado na
tecnologia de células-tronco
pluripotentes induzidas
e Isso poderá ser feito de duas maneiras
a primeira
mas é presente né me tempo está
relacionado com órgãos Fantasmas E por
incrível que pareça eu temos científico
para esse órgão para esse tipo de
tecnologia também nessa figura vocês vem
órgãos de animais do quando o
vermelhinho é como o órgão é dentro do
animal né então com as células e em
branco vocês vem o que é esse órgãos em
célula nenhuma então fica só estrutura
né O que o que não é Vivo daquele órgão
E aí como você consegue a partir das
células-tronco induzida gerar qualquer
tipo de célula você vai poder preencher
esse órgão que não tem rejeição com as
suas células para de fato não ter
rejeição aqui é de animal mas para
humana também existe em diversos órgãos
que já foram alcançados né órgãos
fantasmas
Oi e aí é um passo além que um pouquinho
mais para frente está relacionado com a
bioimpressão de órgãos
e obviamente a gente ouve cada vez mais
falar de
desculpa impressora 3D né E tem também a
sbe o impressoras 3D e científicamente
descobre-se cada vez mais materiais que
não são tóxicos para o ser humano e que
podem criar estrutura do órgão de
maneira eficiente então é com a mesma
ideia você faz a estrutura do órgão a
partir da célula-tronco induzida você
gera as células específicas daquele
órgão
repovoar aquele aquela estrutura e tem o
seu órgão pronto para colocar em você no
momento que você precisar é e aqui eu
poderia ir para o ficção científica
longe assim permitir e a gente mas eu
vou parar aqui porque tá mais próximo da
gente assim isso provavelmente deve
acontecer 15 anos e foi pensando em
todas essas aplicações
que surgiu a policial by a tecnologia
junto com durante o meu doutorado e
junto com meu orientador e um amigo
também biólogo da graduação
Nós abrimos a empresa com o objetivo de
fazer células humanas especializadas a
partir de células-tronco induzidas e
aplicar essas células nas suas mais
diversas aplicações e principalmente
nessas aqui que eu mostrei para vocês
e no meu doutorado que eu fiz lá na
Instituto do Coração no Hospital das
Clínicas em São Paulo é obviamente a
trabalhava com coração e
consequentemente a primeira célula que a
empresa gerou foram as células do
coração vocês podem ver aqui nesse vídeo
tão no vídeo de trás Isso é uma massa de
células eu tenho aqui alguns milhares de
células tem como colocar em loop ou não
tudo bem
então atrás tem são muitas células e que
representada aqui nesse vídeo Menorzinho
da frente uma unidade de uma célula
cardíaca tem um corações os corações de
vocês têm alguns bilhões dessa célula
hoje isso a empresa já faz isso tem essa
célula disponível e está em andamento
também células do fígado e células da
pele e com a ideia de se criar também
uma pele artificial
e os próximos passos da empresa seriam
fazer essas células em em larga escala
Por que
ter essas células em larga escala Seria
a primeira necessidade para que fosse
possível produzir um órgão artificial
tona um grande riso po a policial tem a
ideia né de ser a empresa pioneira no
Brasil
e na construção de órgãos artificiais
com com a vontade de trazer essa
tecnologia que hoje ainda tá um
pouquinho distante do Brasil para gente
e tornar ela acessível para a sociedade
brasileira no momento que ela estiver
disponível no mundo inteiro bom era isso
que eu queria falar muito obrigada